uğur
böcekli bu kırmızı dairenin ortasında
olmak benim için büyük bir heyecan bu
dairenin etrafında çok fazla oldum
bestesi çok fazla oldum sahiden robot
düşürdüm Bilişim zirvesi'nde çok fazla
etkinlik yaptım çok fazla yaptım 24 ana
haber bülteninde konu oldu teknolojinin
dijitalin Bilişimin farkındalığı
konusunda çok fazla emek harcadım
tehditler aldım kavgalar ettim ama bugün
bu kırmızı çemberin ortasında sızladı
dijital ve teknoloji anlatmak için
burada olduğu için çok mutluyum böyle
bir vizyon için müthiş konuşmacılar
olmuş Harika bir sunum olmuş organize
olarak söyleyeyim Antalya'daki şu an
yapılmış en kaliteli içerik Dedesini
gerçekleştirir büyük Alkışı rica
ediyorum Çok satılır
buna bir nebze olsun katkıda bulunmak
benim için müthiş bir gurur bitti keyif
sevgili Oğlum burada onu böyle garip bir
Totemi var Ben böyle ne zaman bir yere
gitsem böyle Barbie oyuncak verir ba ba
ba da bunu alırmısın dır aldım geldim
şimdi Aytun oyuncağıyla bu sunum yapıyor
olacağım öyle etkinliklerin seminerleri
konferanslar gidiyorum yaklaşık 400 den
fazla konferansta konuştu arkadaşlar Az
önce arkadaşım bir soru hocam
heyecanlanıyor musun Ne diyorsun
ölüyorum heyecandan çıkıp her seferinde
heyecanlanıyor Sun on beş gün saat ders
anlatmışım teknoloji tasarım dersleri
400'den fazla konferans Anadolu'nun her
yerinde ama sahnede olmak muhteşem bir
keyif muhteşem bir motivasyon sevgili
arkadaşlar konuşacağımız konu dijital
nesil bugün teması da zaten dijitalleşme
ve Dijital Teknoloji teknoloji mi olduğu
yerde teknolojinin olduğu noktada zaman
zaman insanı kaçırır olsak da ben size
bugün biraz insanın hikayesini alacağım
aslında kendi teknolojide işimizi ve
insanlık Hikayemiz anlatıyor olacağım
ülkemizde dünyada aslında aynı şeyler
oluyor ve hiçbir birbirinden farklı
şeyler değil ben sektörü çok fazla Adobe
Apple sert Fight reynir işte Master
trainer çok farklı ünvanlarla dijital
Dünya Bu yazılım Bilişim sektöründe
danışmanlık tasarımcılık yazılımcılık
çok farklı gömleklerde bulunmuş hibrit
bir Bilişim insanıyım bana soruyor Hocam
hangi kuşak dansın Vallahi bilmiyorum
yani sorsanız Ben bilgisayarın
başındayken zevk uşağıyım ama
bilgisayarı kapatıp olumlu oynarken 12
kuşağı imama bambaşka bir şey yaparken
iş görüşmesinde müşteri görüşmesinde dün
Gaziantep deyim toplantı masasında bir
Holding masasında tam bir gece kuşu ayıp
Ben buna inanıyorum hepimiz farklı
yaşlarımız da farklı farklı farklı
kuşaklara büyüyoruz bunu da iddia
ediyorum her katılmayanlar varsa da
tarihimiz zaman hepimizi bir şekilde
haklı çıkaracak diye düşünüyorum bakın
İnternet diye bir kavram geldi bizim
hayatımızda sevgili arkadaşlar bundan
yaklaşık bir 30 yıl önce 1990'lı yıllar
ve internet dediğimiz kavram bizim için
muazzam bir yenilik muazzam bir popüleri
teyidi ve biz internetten nasıl geldik
biliyor musunuz Bakın bu haberler
hatırlayan var mı Evet arkadaşlar
internet kafelerin açılışı mankenlerle
beraber yapılıyordu oldu yani haber
bülteni oluyor bakın ablaların önünde
Türkiye'nin şimdinin bayağı x kuşağı
böyle sanki güne gitmişler gibi
oraletler öyle Grup hastalarda
internette geldik o zaman İnternetin de
biliyor musunuz istatik internet ve 10
dediğimiz kavram Yani hiçbir şekilde
etkileşim yapamıyorsunuz mesaj göndermek
yok Sadece video izliyorsunuz müzik
izliyorsunuz haber okuyorsunuz yani
internet bu biz bunun için süsleniyor
duk kalkıyor duk kafede oturuyorduk
internete geldim diyorduk bakın
internete bağlanmak bu kadar bu kadar
kıymetliydi ve yerimizden kalkıyordu ve
bakın yan taraftaki fotoğraf ODTÜ'de
1990'lı yıllarda internet hattı
çekiliyor makaralarla
bu mühendis bu abiler bu adamlar
sayesinde Ülkemizde ilk internete bağlan
sotillo gerçekleştirebiliyorsunuz ve
Bugünlerde ise buraya şu an hepimizin
neredeyse 50 küçük cihazlarda evdeki
buzdolabında en aptal cihazlarımızı bir
internet bağlantısı var ama o gün biz
bir haber okuyabilmek için bir
megabaytlık biri transfer edebilmek için
bile bu devasa makaralarla kabloları
çekiyorduk ve şimdi dijital Çağın tam
merkezinde ise dijital çağı oluşturan
jital çağı bütünleştiren ve geliştirecek
geliştiren Siz Yani aslında biz hepimiz
ben kesin kabakuşak konusunda hak eden
farklı Çünkü ben bir x kuşağı bir
yatırımcıyla çalışıyorum benden çok daha
fazla ileri görüşlü ütopik olabiliyor
arkadaşlar Yeter ki motivasyonunuzu
kaynağınız doğru nokta kullanacak etmez
bu dijital Can Bir parçasıyız tüm
dünyada az önce bir güncelleme yaptım
beş milyara yaklaşmış internet
kullanıcısı 4.7 milyar sosyal medya
kullanıcısı var Facebook'un tek başına
iki milli daha fazla aktif kullanıcısı
var ülkelerden daha etkili ve bu kadar
bilgi bu kadar da dünyayı değiştiriyor
arkadaşlar ve muhteşem bir ekosistem
içerisindeyiz farkındamısınız bu
ekosistemin ana kaynağı ana hedefi
sensin İnsan insanı alıyor bu insana
teknoloji para ve iletişim vaad ediyor
ona da öğretmesi için fırsatlar sunuyor
ama senden yine da da alıyor değil mi
İşte arkadaşlar İçinde bulunduğumuz
dünyanın hammaddesi en değerli
hammaddesi data Petrol değil altın değil
yani bilgi Ya kim ne yapsın benim ne
yediğimi öyle düşünmeyin Yapay Zeka
dediğimiz teknoloji blok şeyin teknoloji
dijital dünyayı dijital nesil idat
oluşturuyor sevgili arkadaşlar biz
önemsedim önemsemediğimiz veriler ve
datalar sayesinde geleceğimizi inşa
etmeye başlıyoruz ve bu dijital
ekosistem giderek büyüyor ve bakın Bugün
kendine ait bir para birimi var ödeme
sistemi var blok Çin teknoloji diyoruz
biz buna siz Bitcoin olarak bir O çok
fazla öyle biliyor ama yazılım Dünyası
blok şeyin teknolojisiyle bir çok şeyi
değiştirdi sertifikasyon sistemi Ödeme
Sistemleri transfer sistemleri dünyayı
bu teknoloji değiştirecek arkadaşlar
internet nasıl bizi değiştirdiyse blok
çayı teknolojide bunu değiştirecek ha
Bugün birazcık Spor Toto mantığını ama
değil işin tmm yediğinizde blok şeyin
teknolojisi muhteşem bir imkan fırsatlar
Deniz suyu ve bugüne gelelim en eski
dediğimiz bir kavram da ortaya çıkmaya
başladı dijital bir ekosistem var
dijital ödeme sistemi var dijital Para
var ama ne yok dijital varlık artık o da
var nam-ı falan cılt akım dediğimiz
sevgili arkadaşlar blokçeyn
teknolojisinin eşsiz varlıkları yani
dijital dünyayı oluşturacağımız en eski
varlıkları ve Dijital tasarımları
oluşturmaya başladık Ben bir
tasarımcıyım alırız tasarım sil dijital
tasarımlar yapıyorum Ve tasarımlarımı bu
dijital dünya için yapıyorum Aslında
meteorolojisi konuşuyoruz dijitalleşmeye
konuşuyoruz ve Dijital evrenleri inşa
etmeye başladık bu kadar var bunun
içinde 20 yıldır biz dijital evrenleri
sanal evrenleri oluşturmak için mücadele
ettik savaştık ve bu günlere geldik
Arkadaşlar bu dijital Evrenler bu
dijital dünyada meteoris bizim bugünümüz
ve geleceğimiz bugün adına meteor
istiyoruz Yarın bambaşka bir şey
diyebiliriz ki bambaşka şey dememiz
gerekiyor Çünkü teknoloji ve
dijitalleşme hiçbir zaman olduğu yerde
durmaz Neden Çünkü insan durduğu yerde
durmaz arkadaşlar insan istek ve
ihtiyaçları değiştikçe
dijitalleşme teknoloji değişir
problemler değişir çözümler değişir Ben
bir düzen King eğitmeliyim tasarım
odaklı düşünce eğitmeliyim bu konuda
alanda ilk ve tek Türkçe kitabı Yazdım
şu an 7 üniversiteden kaynak kitap
kullanıyor ben ilk kitabı yazmaya
başladığımda deli misin saçmalık
Saçmalama kim ne yapsın Design thinking
Apple var burada dedi ama şu an
neredeyse bütün şirketler dijitalleşmeye
inovasyonu tasarımcı gibi düşünerek yani
dijital bakış açısına sahip olarak
yapıyor dijital Dünya en önemli
etkinliklerinden bir tanesi tasarımcı
Gibi Düşünmek yani teknolojiyi tasarımla
sanallaşma ile görselleştirme ile
zenginleştirmek arkadaşlar ve bu kadar
çalışmamalı süreç niye yeni bir insan
türü your dijital İnsan işte dijital
Nestle inşa ediyoruz Bu da yaş farkı yok
Milliyet farkı yok hangi ülkede
olduğunuzu ne giydiğinizi bir önemi yok
dijital İnsan olun yeter Çünkü sen
Facebook için sadece bir dijital
varlıksın bir dijital insansın yani ona
sadece bir kaynak sın artık parçalara ve
Petrol kuyuları ihtiyaç yok dijital Ee
kim yapıyorlar Biz hepimiz bir tarla
ömrünü gibiyiz arkadaşlar ve Dijital
dünya Bizi bir hasat ürünü gibi
kullanıyor bizden aldığı hasat ettiğim
data sayesinde İşte bu yeni nesil insanı
inşa etmeye başlıyor bu yeni nesil insan
ne yapıyor yenisiyle yeni bir kitleyi
oluşturmaya başlıyor bakın al fakuşağı
diyoruz e kuşağı diyoruz iki kuş Allah
hepimizin birbirinden farklı eksikleri
var ve zayıf noktaları var ama şimdiki
nesil e bakın 7-8 yaşlarındaki çocuklara
bütün dünya avuçlarının içinde mi
bölgeler adamlar 78 yaşında programlama
öğreniyor Algoritma öğreniyor Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği öğrencisi 21 yaşında
algoritmayı öğreniyor programlama
öğrenin Ama bu çocuklar 28 yaşında
programını bilerek geliyor Geldim diyor
Şimdi ben Bilişim Akademisi sahibim en
çok lise çağındaki çocuklara yazılım
eğitim vermeye çalışıyorum en çok onlar
bana bunu talebini getir Üniversitesi
daha da Ortaokulu daha da düşecek Çünkü
Dijital Teknoloji geliştirme üretim ve
Çağı ne kadar düşerse o kadar buz
pastadan pay alabilirsiniz dünya
dijitalleşme Jack Teknoloji gelişti bunu
duramayız numara şansımız yok
kötüleyerek dijitalleşmeye şöyle böyle
bundan kaçamayız buradan pay almak
zorundayız burayı yönlendirmek
zorundayız televizyona olan at adetimiz
Neyse İnternet olan tertemiz Neyse
dijital olana temiz de bu Sevgili
dostlar çok ve iletişim kurmak
istiyorsanız çocuğumuz bir ekran
bağımlısı isago oturun yanına Onunla
beraber oyun oynayın onun motivasyonu
anlayın Empati kurmak zorundasınız Çünkü
siz sokakta Top oynayarak motive
olduğunuz bu adam fortnite a haritaları
atlayarak level atlayarak motive oluyor
Onların duygusunu motivasyon anlamak
lazım değil mi tweet attım Allah'ım
özelden yemediğim hakaret kalmadı
gençlerin tarafında durduğum için Sizi
anlamak zorundayız Empati kurmak
zorundayız Biz bizim zamanımızda böyle
bizim zamandır şöyle demek sevgili
arkadaşlar sadece havanda su dövmek
oluyor sizinle beraber bu dünyayı inşa
etmemiz lazım birden şöyle bir
kolaycılık görüyorum Gelecek gençlerin
yani onlar bu dünyayı batırıyor Hadi ya
biz de yaşıyoruz sosyal medyayı kaç tane
Z kuşağı kullanıyordur en çok sosyal
medya internet kullanan kim Sen gel
Aslında bu çocuklar değil daha çok biz
kullanıyoruz bir deformasyon varsa bunu
biz yaptık onlar değil Onlar şu an bizim
oluşturduğumuz dünyanın içerisinde devam
ediyor yeni dünyanın süper gücü sevgili
arkadaşlar Hayal kurmak dijital bir
nesil kurmak istiyorsanız hayal gücüne
sahip olmak zorundasınız Ben demiyorum
Albert Einstein diyor ki zekanın gerçek
göstergesi bilgi değil Hayal gücüdür
bakın dünyanın bütün gün şirketleri bu
güç sayesinde yaratıcı Özgüven sayesinde
hayal gücü sayesinde bu kadar büyük ve
gelişmiş durumda da hayal gücü her şey
demektir sizi bekleyen güzellikleri bir
fragmanı gibidir diyor yani bilginin
babası beyni kavanoz içinde duran bir
adamdan bahsediyorum Hayal gücünden
bahsediyor bilmek yetmiyor hayal etmek
hayalin ötesini görmek gerekiyor bakın
neden bu kadar hayal gücü diyoruz in
Turkey 1006 yılında bir araştırma
yapıyor bütün dünyada girişimcilik
hayalperesti kalıp başına giderken bu
ülkede sıkıntı var bu ülkeden unicorn
çıkmıyor dekom Çıkmıyor WhatsApp o
çıkmıyor Hala sanayileşme hala toplu
iğneyi Yüksek Teknoloji ürünü olarak
konuşmaya çalışıyoruz ve bu haritasına
göre arkadaşlar diyor ki bu ülkede temel
problem İnsanların hayal kurmayı
bilmezsin soruyor yüz kişiden sadece
15'i Benim bir hayalim var Ben hayal
kurmayı biliyorum diyor geriye kalan
gitti 85hp 15 kişi Tamam işimizi görür
on beş kişiden de WhatsApp Facebook
çıkarabiliriz diyelim Ama ilerliyorum
bu 15 kişinin de Yüzde 48 sadece meslek
sahibi olmayı hayal ediyor Yani bir
mesleğin olsun da ne olursa olsun diyor
Gerçekten hayal kurmayı bilmiyoruz
kurduğumuz hayaller gerçek hayat
sanıyoruz 126 zengin olmayı düşünüyor ne
olursa olsun zengin olayım da işimize
yarayan dört beş kişi var Bu dört beş
kişi de yolda ekonomik siyasi ve torpil
vesaire sebepten ötürü sayılıyor ve
bizden WhatsApp Facebook işte ne bileyim
birde Kuran çıkmıyordu ama 2006'dan
sonra İşte bu bizim şu an kızdığımız ev
bu sayesinde oyun teknolojisinde bu ülke
neredeyse bir numara olmak üzere değil
mi getir neredeyse dünyanın en büyük
girişim olmak üzere işte bir şeyler
değişiyor O yüzden bunu nesile sahip
çıkıp bu nesile bir oturup oyun
oynamadığımız sürece onlarla ürün
teknoloji geliştirme yiz nüfusumuz genç
ama hayallerimiz yaşlı Sevgili dostlar
Şimdi bunu değiştirmemiz lazım nüfusu
muzu da gençlerimiz de aynı oranda
kullanırsak Hayal kurmaya onlara
üretirsek özgüvenlerini değiştirirsek
ülkemizde değişir dünyada değişir diye
düşünüyorum Ben geçen yıl 20'den fazla
Mühendislik Fakültesi gezdim
hepsini tek tek görüşüyorum yazılım
mühendisi bilgisayar mühendisi hayaline
diye soruyorum Bir ülkenin mühendis
adaylarının hayali KPSS ise o ülkede
gerçek ve Kalkınma bekleyemezsiniz
Arkadaşlar en büyük temelimiz zaten bu
mühendis arkadaşlarımızın Hayal kurmayı
öğrenmesi gerekiyor teknoloji bilişimi
geliştirmesini onlardan bekliyor Sak
doğru motivasyonu onlara sağlamamız
lazım Peki nasıl ulaşacağız Arkadaşlar
doğru düşünerek bu doğru düşünce doğru
Fikri doğurur doğru fikirde doğru ürünü
doğru yani yapabilirim dememiz gerekiyor
öncelikle ve yapabildiğimiz göstermek
için de geleceği ortaya çıkarmak için de
tasarımcı gibi Düşünmeniz bir inovatif
düşünce ve yaratıcı düşünce ihtiyacımız
var Davut normal Apple'ın kıdemli yük
tasarımcısı diyor ki Mühendisler ve
insanların Sorun çözmek için iyidir ama
tasarımcılar henüz var olmayan sorunları
yani geleceği inşa etmekten bahsediyor O
yüzden geleceği tasarımcı gibi bakarak
yırtıcı özgüveninizi birlikte bakmanız
ve geliştirmemiz gerekiyor Bunun içinde
sevgili arkadaşlar Deneyim kazanmak
zorundasınız bakın deneyim dünyanın en
kıymetli öğretmeni denemekten korkmayın
evet Bilgisayar başında oturup zaman
geçirmez sadece elenerek değil üreterek
de oyun içerisinde yer almaya çalışın
oyun yazın oyun geliştirin kod yazın
dijital dünyaya ürün geliştirin o zaman
bir şeylerin değiştiğini göreceksiniz
başarısız olmak dünyanın en kıymetli
öğretmeni ilan Master 2 başarısız
olmakta seçeneklerden bir 300 yeterince
başarısız olmadıysanız yeterince
yenilikçi değilsiniz bizim Buna
ihtiyacımız var icat çıkarın çocuklar
başarısız olun başarı ancak öyle geliyor
Ben sade robot düşürdüm Gün etkinlik
yapmaktan vazgeç Seydi bugün vites
organizer olmayacaktım 7 hakkını biçim
servisi altıncı akla düşüncesini
yapmayacaktım arkadaşlarada bugün burada
olmayacaktım o yüzden
başarısızlıklarında sarılın ve onları
geliştirmeye çalışın Problem her yerde
var dünyanın heryerinde Anadolu'nun
göbeğinde siniz dünya bir Survivor
ortamı ise Türkiye Survivor'ın en Zorlu
parkuru ama yine çözüm bu toprakların ta
kendisinin Hz Mevlana diyor ki Soru
neredeyse cevap oradadır yoksulluk
neredeyse Nimet oraya gider gemi
neredeyse su oradadır Lütfen arayın
Anadolu'nun içinde yaşıyorsunuz kendi
medeniyetimize sarılarak doğruluğu
aramak zorunda Dünya neden başarıyor
arkadaşlar Çünkü sürekli denemeye ona
yapıyor dünyanın en çok patent yapan
ülkelerin görüyorsunuz Biz deneme
yanılma yapmıyoruz biz ar-ge'ye para
harcamıyoruz Bu sadece sadece zaman
öldürüyoruz hadi kullanıcı tarafındayız
artık oyun Kur'an tarafta Bence olmak
durumundayız ve bunun içinde kendimizi
keşfetmemiz gerekiyor Ben kendimi
keşfederek yola çıktım 24 tercihin
24'ünde bilgisayar programcılığı yazdım
ben Eğer bugün bir şeyler yaptıysam
Sadece buna borçluyum başka şeyler de
yapabilirdim benden ne olur benden ne
olması cevap verebiliyorsanız çok şey
başarabilirsiniz ve işte her şey bu
dünyanın içerisinde parmaklarınızın
ucunda her şey parmaklarımız Bunu kim
söylüyor hatırlayan var mı Video
parmaklarının ucunda her şey parmakları
ucunda diyordu televizyonda bizim kuşak
oturdu Tolga abi ile yıllarca Hipo
izledik bende izledim ben de izledim
sonra ne oldu Ben fakir bir ailenin
çocuğu turizmi tane babanın evladı
hayatım boyunca arayamadım ama dedim Ne
güzel oynuyorlar Telefonunuz kapalıydı
Sonra oldu biliyor musunuz Ben Tolga abi
ortak oldum arkadaşlar
Bu aracın yok diye bir şirket kurduk ben
Tolga abi ile 8 tane bu uygulama
şirketine ortak olduk bugün Bakırköy
şube de çalışıyorum arkadaşım aradı
emerken seni biriyle tanıştıracağım dedi
beklettim Tolga abi evrak çıkmıyor
nasılsın dedi aynı basayım eşin
bahsediyorsun Adam ne dese yapıyorsun
Böyle bir dünyanın içerisinde her şey
parmaklarının ucunda Hugo parmaklarının
ucunda a dedim ben parmağıma doğru geri
hareket ettirdim arkadaşlar kedi
videosunu izleyebilirsiniz
Bu netflix bölümlerde bitirebilirsiniz
ama Yapay Zeka da öğrenebilirsiniz blok
Çin teknoloji öğrenebilirsiniz
parmağınızın ucunda her şey parmağınızı
doğru yere doğru kullanın Ben doğru yere
doğru kullandığım için bir gün Tolga abi
Hem aile dostu hem ortak hem de birlikte
çalışma imkanı yakalım şu ikinci
fotoğraf sabahladı ımız İstanbul'da bir
oyun yazılımın lansman gecesi muhteşem
bir keyif daha az ve benim için de
çocukluğumun Aslında bir nevi Aslında
öcünü aldım finalde başarılı hale geldi
arayamadım ama şimdi kolum burada
dediğim noktaya getirdim hikayede benim
için hiçbir hikaye motivasyon ama sizin
Siz yoksa gelen maske ihtiyacınız yok
Sizin zaten muhteşem bir motivasyon
kaynağımız var Çok teşekkür ederim çok
sağ ol